well I think this person does exist but
it's really confined primarily to the
opposition party to the supporters of
the opposition party and we saw the same
thing really during the Bush
administration particularly the last two
years of the Bush administration there
were a lot of angry voters out there but
at that time they were there were almost
all Democrats who were upset about
things like the war in Iraq about Bush
administration's you know economic and
environmental policies and so on now
with a Democratic president in Congress
it's the Republicans especially the more
engaged Republicans who are angry
they're angry because they disagree you
know with the Democrats on issues like
health care and budgetary priorities and
so on so yes I mean I think there are
angry voters out there i think sometimes
it gets a little overblown you know
because i'm not sure that voters are
really angry or overall now than they
have been in the past I think it's just
that we're seeing more visible
manifestations of that with these Tea
Party demonstrations
well they're not angry anymore because
now for the most part because you have a
Democratic president that now the some
of them might still not be thrilled with
all of the things the Obama
administration has done but by and large
I think what you find is that there's
been a reversal you know that you know
it's sort of like the the anger has gone
over from once hi to the to the other
not right now you know because again
it's harder I think for people to get
worked up when you know they're in the
majority that especially in midterm
elections we tend to see that it's the
disgruntled people who are the most
active we saw that in 2006 where it was
really the Democrats by and large who
were the most enthusiastic at the most
engaged and now it's the Republicans you
know with the Democrat in the White
House so it's sort of part of the normal
cycle of American politics that's what
tends to happen in these in these
midterm elections is just that with
increasing polarization you know I think
what happens now is that these swings
become greater and the reaction becomes
even stronger